okay 24 was it Kel Dorne all right some
new players from the new time that I'm
streaming okay let's see what we have
more Sicilian why not okay specially
cough okay it is open Knight c3 e5 is
coming up and my opponent is saying that
the stream is muted do I believe that
night be five is the most testing by
default that's what I want to go forward
with I see that this is also fine i'm
going to try that I'll try it my king is
safe we're going to get into a quick
ending okay so now what suppose this
happens what do you do should I be
afraid of double def ponds hmm
just going to avoid any imbalance I was
thinking that my other option was King
c7 and the reason it's okay to you know
be on Castle is because the Queen's are
off and my king is going to have a
perfectly safe home on c7 however
another good home might be what square
it might be e 7 what are some other
things some other things to note are
concerning the bishops which ones are
good which ones are bad I think being
aware of that concept will allow you to
know that maybe night here is if it's
not the best move to be making it
certainly one to be considering because
it's welcoming my bad bishop for my
opponents good bishop and if their
exchange my king is perfect on e seven
it is an endgame my king is in the
center and contributing in a good way so
now what
I don't have any other choice if the
bishop takes but what if it doesn't take
what if it goes to e3 I think I get out
of the pin right away and okay to be
honest I don't know how I would follow
up exactly things are much more smooth
right now for me but if Bishop e3 King
c7 I was thinking about for a moment
Bishop c5 but it fails tactically to
rook takes night with check first and
only then Bishop to exposure this night
is out of play because of just a silly
little pond on c6 if i play my knight to
f6 the pond plays here and similar to
how my pawn is boxing out this one the F
palm would be boxing out my night from
making use of let's say G for which
could be maybe be a little bit
disruptive if it if it's able to I both
f2 and III so that said my my thoughts
here are now night see 5 or Knight b6 or
b-five maybe that's better I'm gonna go
with that I want some more information
about the address of this fish up in
fact if it goes to be three one thing
that I could look forward to is now
night c5 with the follow up being a five
and if as soon as the a pawn moves then
I take the bishop and my opponent is
having to take away from the center is
that really a structure in let's say a
3b 3b to structure is that really going
to be exploitable I'm not so sure
nevertheless I think night c5 is the
best pressure on both Bishop and pawn
and is threatening pawn push I don't
know if I would really end up winning
upon night takes has always met with
something like rook here and there's two
unprotected pieces on the e-file so
anyhow it's supported a for this pond
would have to move I could we could
enter of course a night versus bishop
ending where I'm the side that has the
bishop maybe let me do let me do this
actually
yeah let me let me do this a five so big
decision now for white you go one or two
I really don't know which one is best ah
let's see do I take this [ __ ] up do I
push first now i'm down on time maybe
actually keep this these pot in the
ponds flexibility now maybe I should
just take no no no no no no I got it I
take here and then I pinpoint this pun
the King has to step up how do I make
progress I need to I need to create
another weakness somehow somehow pawn
push is met with here and then I have
possibilities for overtaking control the
defiled just because I could control D 1
if I could control be three I control D
1 and if I could control D one I might
be able to control the D file a little
domino effect right there a little some
logic to follow so what else is there to
do is that I guess that's the other move
that was being considered and I guess a
for takes takes I could get here but
maybe my a pond becomes a problem so I
just don't know maybe I could think
about the other side of the board g5
with g4 to follow one pair of brooks is
going to come off the board
hmm I'm push takes takes Bishop b3 I
don't know how big of a now what am I
talking about my egg pod could be a
target it's not gonna be a target is it
I don't know let me do this first I I'm
down two min I can't I did that the best
explaining and thinking that I could do
right now up to this point I have to
move faster just I'm trying to do
something I want to maybe somehow create
a target on the the King side of the
board I'm not sure what's going to come
about on this side okay I don't think it
really matters but no it does matter
actually take with this and now get
something like this going I want to keep
my rook here and I want to create some
target over here I want to keep my
opponent guessing pond Porsche pawn push
see the reason I don't want to kick this
night right away is because it's just
I'm shape it's a it's a case of chasing
the night to square it might have
already wanted to go to be four maybe
takes right away or take our just moves
right away to a four however you slice
it be for the night makes use of a 4 but
after a four be for the night of course
can't do that and I'm really most
concerned about this night finding a
good home I don't want to allow it to
let's say make use of d5 for this whole
game I was never considering moving this
pun and now I think I do what I probably
should be creating some pawn exchange
soon
hmm this could turn out to be a problem
that the night tries to go into here I
could take it and I think targeted at
some point well that's actually maybe a
bit far off we're going to see night g3
maybe g4 is best I'm going to work on
the King side if pawn push then this
pond I want to I want to get my bishop
here one day and kind of gone to pac-man
mode so I'm looking to now play on this
side of the board and I think it'll
start like this i'm looking for a pawn
push and then maybe taking with the rook
and then i'm targeting this square this
rook is on an open file but notice that
there's no entry point so I'm not too
concerned about that this night can
maybe try and get into this square hmm
might see one I'm going to try this and
I'm going to take with my rook just so
the night can't make use of that square
so easily and now that the night isn't
on c3 to get to this square maybe I
could allow my sepan to now contribute
pawn push and then this so I'm
supporting my book so I could get in
this advanced I'm opening things up
which is benefiting my bishop pawn push
is going to be cramping to the night and
the exchange of rooks is one that I
really don't want and I was have an
outside passed pawn as well my rook is
very active I was saying before about my
bishop wanting to get here my rook quick
oh I only have 10 seconds I want to
maybe even get my rook there I get that
working to e1 I think King here and then
look here the King kind of goes back and
forth didn't go there it's dropping a
poem the night is boxed out this is a
one king and pawn in game
making progress now okay down on time oh
good game that was the first time he
played and a good game it was all right
let's go back let's put that board so
rare to see it start out with an open
Sicilian and we quickly get into an end
game out of the session akov and it was
because of this night capture which I
really can't recommend my other option
is just to be taking with my beep on and
then this ensuing d5 move which you
really can't prevent maybe we could
prevent it for a little bit but with
correct preparation excuse me I'll be
able to get that in and overtake central
control i'll be able to eliminate your
only central pawn or maybe even push
forward and start kicking your pieces
around so i would really shy away from
Knight takes Knight I think it works out
quite okay for black no matter how you
recapture and we saw maybe I think this
was maybe the first time on stream that
I captured with the deep on when when we
when we did have a capture on that
square but night be fives the other one
to really be going with the most testing
so in this end game black is quite all
right I think you do better when there
is this tension to hang on to your
bishop recognizing which which bishops
are good which ones are bad this is your
good guy this is your bad guy this is my
good guy this is my bad guy and we're
I'm welcoming my bad bishop for your
good Bishop exchange I think you should
be avoiding that and dropping back to
let's say III and again I can't
challenge it with Bishop here because
I'm in a pin but even if I'm out of the
pin with King c7 again there would be
rook takes Knight removing the defender
of c-5 so it's a bit tricky I think
dropping your Bishop back is going to be
an improvement but after that exchange I
really don't have any issue and it's
really you who has to now be careful
because of me
having the bishop which is going to be
good since there's bishops on both sides
of the board in this end game 1 pair of
brooks comes off you'll know i challenge
this rook only after it moved only when
there was the threat of may be doubling
i wanted to keep one brook on the board
if it's just if it's just what if it's
just a night versus bishop ending i
don't know if i could really put to use
that that bishop i'm seeing stuff like
be three or excuse me be four in the
night or just kind of clamping down on
this dark square and the king could kind
of come over here it'd be very difficult
to win i thought my best chance was to
keep one rook on the board so i could
start to get active in some way the King
side is officially shut down after this
more long-term again i was looking to
get a g2 but that didn't really happen i
think in this final position the best is
just to kind of go back and forth with
the king good game very very good game
but as it stood we had a king and pawn
in game which is going to turn out to be
winning but we had no time to finish it